we actually the funny story let's let's
jump to this next this next story do
actually have I do here it is oh yeah
this is kind of funny wealthy tenants
are squatting in multi-million dollar
homes in the Hamptons and Hamptons and
refusing to pay rent
after NY issued a non eviction order due
to the coronavirus crisis of course I
will simultaneously say these people are
extremely lucky and they're also really
bad people so I'll give you the gist the
story when the breakdown
you know when the lockdown started
happening wealthy people in New York
fled leaving behind all the poor people
all the shuttered businesses right and
they go to the Hamptons then New York
State says moratorium on evictions so
the people who are in these big mansions
now are like I was only planning on
being here until August yeah you can't
evict me I'm not paying yeah there you
go that's crazy so so basically I bring
this up in in in the context of with
these lockdowns cities are it's it's
almost like a pressures being applied to
them that's forcing people out in
various directions you know all of the
wealthy people though what will this end
up doing to these cities they're gonna
lose massive political power they're
probably gonna they're probably gonna
end up losing congressional seats cuz
it's a census year it's going to change
the ideology of so many people they take
so many things for granted and then I
wonder if 2024 it's gonna be you know
538 Republican vote yeah like everybody
is when I heard that story of people in
New York and LA like flocking to gun
stores yeah I laugh yeah that's pretty
funny yeah all of a sudden our crisis
happens and they all instantly become
second Amendment advocates yeah let's
read this story and sue the wealthy
people are up to and we'll talk then
we'll talk about New York collapsing
some wealthy tenants in the Hamptons are
using New York's States non eviction
order to squat in luxury while
weathering out the coronavirus crisis
local landlords have claimed one
homeowner who chose to remain anonymous
but identified as middle class said that
short-term renters are over staying at
his property in Sag Harbor and refusing
to pay rent properties in the Hamptons
rent for much less in the winter and
early spring months when the corona
virus outbreak began but can ask for
thousands more in summer months we're
not talking about poor people
so the anonymous individual told the
post it's a very modest Sag Harbor house
and we use our summer rental to pay our
son school the squatter was paying
$3,600 a month between October and March
but claimed he didn't have rent for
April and dismissed the homeowners
request to vacate the property the
landlord said he is now looking at huge
losses for the year $15,000 in May alone
with an extra fifty five thousand
between Memorial Day and Labor days New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo has postponed
rent payments until at least 2025 August
to help those struggling during the
coronavirus crisis the owner believes
his tenants are using it as a free stay
in his Long Island property no that's
definitely what they're doing yeah
similar scenes are playing out along the
string of affluent seaside communities a
female land landlord in water mill
Center tenants a mother and daughter
stopped paying their $1,600 rent in
March when Governor Cuomo announced the
move this is uh this is what people do
why would anybody why would anybody pay
if they were told they didn't have to
they don't care about you exactly the
government said don't pay I'm not gonna
pay that's crazy man there's no
community left so I really curious about
where this all ends up they're talking
about the new normal you know what's the
new normal after this no one shakes
hands anymore we all bow we act a very
Asian like yeah maybe well to masks a
lot of masks it is the the customs
people wear masks more often they don't
shake hands they bow and that'll be just
inherent social distancing but I wonder
if it also the new normal is gonna be
New York loses three congressional seats
I'm exaggerating greatly they've lost
four and 20,000 wealthy people you know
but how many other people have fled the
city how many people have left Los
Angeles or spread out maybe and maybe
this was gonna you know greatly I mean
look I'm talking about getting out of
Jersey a blue state mm-hm and going
somewhere else where I can be free you
know and not have to deal with this
stuff yeah so these people are
absolutely taking advantage of this and
I you know these are these are these are
these are New York City Folkman I'm not
surprised
when given the opportunity they take
advantage they're not they're not poor
they don't want to pay they won't you
know they say the homeowner has cancer
and is looking to start chemotherapy
soon she said she is afraid she will
lose her home and doesn't know how
she'll cope with the stress of that and
treatment she could be earning $90,000
this summer she told the post and she
even offered the tenants a one to one
off payment to coax them out before peak
season and now what did they real I've
offered money to leave and even found
her other places to move to that she
could afford but they aren't in the
Hamptons and she is refusing to leave
Tennant says she had this is when we
this is when we make our money in the
summer the tenant is looking for a free
ride in Hamptons I'm really confused by
the story because I don't know exactly
how like an Tifa and the far-left will
react to it you know Who am I supposed
to be mad at the rich people refusing to
pay their fair share or the wealthy
landlords from the Hamptons right it's
just rich people refusing to pay each
other
what the heck it reminds me of this
article that I read is silly it was
basically this person complaining that
they found out there they were being
overcharged for everything from their
private jet like everything cost way too
much they're overcharging me on my every
service on my private jet and I was just
like what are you who are you talking to
you
who's this article I don't care seven
you have the money what does it matter
pay it I don't care you know it's really
really weird oh man they're there
they're there really is this really
interesting class divided mm-hmm so I
know people who do almost no work and
make ridiculous amounts of money just
because of the class they are in you
know so I'll give you an example if
you're if you're a lower class and you
make minimum wage and then you are like
hey look I made this necklace so no bag
I'll give you five bucks for it if you
are upper class and you're sitting on
the beach of you know you're in well
what's what's that what's that place in
in Spain I can't I can't B's ax
Ibiza boom I knew you're darling yes so
you're sitting on this crystal you know
sure clear waters you know and you
leaned over and you're like I made this
beautiful necklace who I wanted how much
$1,000 okay that's that's that's
seriously what it's like it's amazing so
I know people
who are just in the upper class and
there they they're there they talk about
a basic job that normally would be
cheaper but because they're rich they
simply just charge that much money and
the odd it's like they all pay it to
each other so it creates this economy in
an upper level and once you break into
that then you can bask in that as well
and their other what there are other
ways to make a lot of money volume and
stuff but it's fascinating to me when
I've met people who are like I'm going
to get a job starting at this tech firm
I know the person who runs it they're
gonna pay six figures and I'm like why
would they do that that's just because
they're all part of the same class and
then you know and it's also like the
clothes you make yeah right Michael it
with paltrow stuff like is is the GUP
stuff she makes and anyway that special
it's gross yeah yeah you ever see this
you ever see the show called the real
hustle no it's uh it was about it was a
British show I think was British and it
was three con artists explaining various
cons is an awesome show one of them they
rent a pop-up storefront and they buy I
think they bought like Lubriderm lotion
okay and they just repackage it in these
tiny little bottles and they give it a
brand name like you know mountain mist
made okay and then they sell it for like
30 bucks and they just brag about how
it's the best yeah and people pay for it
Wow and that's that's kind of like what
it is when you know when you're doing
trade among people who are poor you can
only ask for so much because of how much
they have when you're doing trade among
people who are rich you can ask for
obscene amounts of money because they
just have it and they pay what they you
know suppose one come look oh yes
absolutely
and so then you have you have a lot of
people man I know some people who are
rich and work like once every three
years it's crazy
yep they'll be like I got one project to
work on this week and they get 300 Rand
and then they're like I just you know
spread it out over three years just you
know eight grand a month to spend
whatever I want fly around take you know
every weekend fly to Europe for a
vacation and then fly back and just do
one thing every few years and that's how
it is yep yeah and those are the people
that are making decisions - those are
the people that are in charge they're
the ones in the government they get a
hold of that they like you said it's
like you can get into that and then then
you become used to it and that's the
type of mentality you you
also so these these officials you know
they might champion for the people but
then they get in there and then they're
like alright now I'm on a different
stage a different level so I'm gonna I'm
gonna stay here and I don't want to lose
this power and I'm gonna make I'm gonna
make decisions for everyone else he's a
great example exactly
you know she everyone makes fun of her
cuz she was a bartender and I'm like
actually think that's kind of endearing
yeah you know that she was a regular
American mm-hm and she won and now she's
in Congress no no yeah right now she
squanders all of that goodwill by being
an insufferable you know what's the word
I'm looking for
you know just desperate for fame and
attention you know ostentatious very
very very much that she goes on Twitter
and she says things that are about
bombastic and insightful and it's just
doing nothing for nobody
inciting I think she might lose New York
is gonna be a transformed place yeah I
think she might lose man I watched a
part of that debate that she did that
other lady and I feel like she's gonna
lose because she's an Internet candidate
she's not a kind of a candidate of a
place
yeah she's Twitter's candidate it's a
good point Twitter's not going to a
lecture though no it's her district that
I like and and good yeah yeah we've seen
what we see we've all seen what Twitter
is like but I you know I can't predict I
can't I can see so many potential
futures you know what could happen after
all this is over mm-hmm
but it's hard to know it's hard it's
hard to know I just absolutely don't can
only just speculate will will with
losing four hundred twenty thousand
people rich people who are enough
squatting in the Hamptons in a census
year does that mean what in 2022 that
New York City loses a district probably
it could be a OCS they've been talking
about getting rid of a district already
yeah and what about all these others
other cities or better yet what if
people already filled out their census
and are now gone permanently hmm and so
now you have smaller populations with
disproportionate amount of power and
then you'll end up seeing really weird
things from this like New York City has
less people but somehow is
over-represented and then you'll end up
with an inversion where the popular vote
goes to the Republican because there's
more people outside of cities
it might you know what my okay so I was
thinking about this while you were
talking
it might go that way because the people
who have to stay in the city are the
people who do the blue-collar jobs the
essential workers and those people tend
to be less college-educated which I'm to
say it they tend to vote Republican they
tend to be conservative so when the time
comes for them to vote they're gonna
vote Republican and they're we're gonna
see I think you're right I think it's
gonna flip it's gonna be really weird
flip flip in what way do you mean though
toward the Republicans like New York
City yeah like that region I think a
Oasys district could turn red I'm
curious because normally like the latwon
Sheeran there was no real real
Republican contender because it's a
d-plus 30 district okay but I think it's
possible that AOC is it's possible I'm
not saying to what what percentage I
know for sure but she's so unpopular
it's possible she's so unpopular that
now that you see all these Republicans
are running they launch real campaigns
generate real support mm-hm and then win
yeah so I know it's a d-plus 30 district
but aoc I think she only got like I
don't know how many how many can you
look at how many votes she got seven no
no in the general oh yeah look in the
general election thing so I think it was
something like a hundred and seventy
maybe I'm not entirely sure out of
750,000 that means even though it's a
d-plus thirty district if the twenty or
thirty percent of Republicans who live
there actually all voted yea they win
yeah and and and new district in New
York would turn red that would be insane
absolutely insane thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you